first answer the question if the
environment is going to lose out to the
economy in 2009 my answer is very simple
it's a clear yes the environment has
always lost to the economy and 2009 it's
not going to be an exception first of
all ways we must recognize them to the
environment is a part of our global
economy and she's not be considered as a
separate entity this is a bit of a
strange question because the economy is
just the amount of training going on if
you look at GDP that's the price of
everything bought and sold lots of
trading GPS up less trading GDP goes
down so there never really was a clash
between the environment and the economy
just depends on what's being traded
trade environmentally fairly goods boost
economic growth also environmental
issues will still be around in 10 years
but the recession won't be the long-term
profits or environmental jobs and the
smart business people will see that
there is hope but for that hope we've
got to correct critical imbalance that
we've got in our economies and that
we've had long before the credit crunch
it's been getting worse over time now
more than ever it's so critical to
correct it you're looking the problem
straight in the eye it's not cars or
light bulbs furnaces or air conditioners
it's not coal miners oil executives or
the tar sands the main problem is what
I'm doing right now freely and lawfully
I'm using fossil fuels for energy so
there you have it when you take the
World Economic Forum and you add in
healthy ecology and you take away the
flow of oil and coal what you're left
with is a healthy environment and a
healthy economy and I think the answer
to this equation is what all world
economists need to include if they're
going to make sure that they have a
healthy economy and healthy environment
in 2009 they need to include youth in
their discussions and furthermore they
need to support hydrogen based
technologies and help us build the
hydrogen economy time is obviously not
on our side
we need to wake up and smell the methane
the time to act is now for socially
responsible investments that can create
green cities clean industries and
sustainable a grocery based economies we
can plant the seeds of hope for a
sustainable future for us all